[Music]
it's thought it all happened it just
wouldn't work
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it begins on a dark okay
[Music]
not gonna find another girl like her in
a million years
it's also magical dunfin I've never
fallen apart right that fast someday to
say
[Music]
I've never before
someday
[Music]
[Music]
I ran away and I am not going back
I am NOT going back
[Music]
I ran away I am NOT going back
let's make some magic
[Music]
[Music]
husband god
have your fun
there's this girl
[Music]
not time in my life help you
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not going back
[Music]
[Music]
Dawkins
[Music]
[Music]
husband
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
husband
[Music]
oh shoot
[Music]
[Music]
for today
[Music]
a little bit of fizzy water you like the
slurp morning meat on the show on the
show it's actually ring tone it just
makes me feel like home alarm his wife
is like gosh not again it's better than
having brian Stelter face on a Sun
rising every morning nothing is better
than you decorate someone you D
legitimize them by making a mockery of
them looks like Chas son of a [ __ ] some
of our plans but we'll see what we get
to with Jeff I am here gerald a is here
in blue in reverse order I'm going to
close I go counterclockwise audio Wade
is here Timmins replacing quarterback
Garrett because he's on the road with
Brendan and Bryce and my half agent
Larry pull Richmond here we have Walt
higher higher on the show a former
transgender individual who switched back
he was on the show a long time ago but
then he got banned from YouTube for
talking about transitioning children and
why he believes it's a bad idea which
naturally was fellows hate speech Wow
yeah he can't even say it no he can't
even say he can't even say it unless he
was on the show he told me that he cut
off Snoopy he used the word Snoopy I
never heard the term and I suppose so
Snoopy Snoopy means penis correct and he
said yes and I said so you have so okay
so you have no peanut he said I do not
and that is why he was horribly
depressed and yours haven't came that
other people don't do that we are going
to go talking about Jimmy come on we're
gonna be talking about Muhammad Ali the
son and why they actually are
surprisingly American nationalists and
we'll be talking about Mel Gibson but
first subscribe to Crowder bits on the
YouTube YouTube now knows that that's
actually a monetized chin so you know a
couple days maybe and subscribe to the a
version on Apple podcasts Android of
course live chat have a lot of credit at
home slash mug Club we do an extra hour
every day and we will read your chats a
little bit later on at blaze TV any
question do you guys think that maybe
canceled culture is what just happened
there being canceled was that that was
what that was the interior
it was the Apple store that's oh why do
we even just have a white screen yeah
with an image of YouTube okay with this
I'm waiting for some kids um X okay
boomer well you know what you're not
really welcome in society create Mel
Gibson do you think cancel culture is
kind of losing its power because no one
has to go after everybody they want to
cancel Jesus Sean King all of them I
think that just because he's mad that
Jesus was more ethnic than him yes yeah
oh not only be one king like the eyebrow
pencil mustache is that
like it's an Armenian woman's eyebrows
yeah yo can I have all this and then I'm
all but use a pencil sharpie because I
don't have time every morning to get
ready that's a good point
what Sean listen I'm just saying it's
more convenient just look at a character
Sean
better go raise money for me my 501c3
let's cancel Jesus all right we're
getting off the beaten path why'd you
come see a little bit Mel Gibson's in
the news before we came uh because he
I'm only laughing because this tells you
how terrible of a world he must have
lived in Winona Ryder came out was
talking about being judged for being too
Jewish not being cast and she claimed
that Mel Gibson called her this Mel
Gibson called her an oven Dodger which
is so unbelievably terrible yeah it's
like you wonder if it's just common
language among these actual anti-semites
surely kind of staring at the reef shelf
and there's this whole world below you
of all these coloring yeah he may not
have come up with it like he's a great
filmmaker but he doesn't seem like you
know like he would come up with a zinger
like I wouldn't want Mel Gibson at a
roast right I couldn't be on his feet
but that being said not wanting to be
someone who jumps on the cancel
bandwagon I also think listen there are
two sides to Mel Gibson and you know
you've heard the voicemails you've read
some of these these I guess tweets
you've read some of these stories but a
lot of you don't hear both sides so we
actually some exclusive and it could be
disturbing to some viewers though but we
do have an exclusive voicemail some
other ones that you may not have heard
from Mel Gibson hey sweetheart I'm going
to be late because there's traffic on
Sepulveda I went to Trader Joe's and I
got everything on the list except I
couldn't get organic raspberries I know
there's a list of organic fruit and a
list of non organic fruit which ones are
safe usually each one was appealed or
like a casing like a watermelon but I
saw the raspberries that were organic
had flowers on them I didn't think you
liked them you wouldn't want them you
wouldn't love them
I couldn't get the peppermint Trader
Joe's the one's a little too Ken on
there looks very festive it turns out
they're seasonal so I got your mango and
I hope they're just as enjoyable Oh be
home and Jen and by the better was still
very upset was still very upset was
that's that's what matters yeah he's
just like running with the groceries I
mean I was like he's breathing so hard
you sound just like it there's no I
don't sound like me today oh come in and
you know talk with my car talk girl
gives me off the cliff
hey really quickly we're gonna move on
to Jimmy Kimmel and something but let's
go to CNN yeah before we move on thanks
very much brand new ad that you may see
soon okay so this is one thing I will
say about CNN even watching this morning
they have gone they've pivoted back from
riots now which were peaceful protests
all the way back to covenant notice that
ticker they should reset it just like
the flu right now yeah if you look at
flu seasons when they said there was
really deadly flu season it typically
stops in April certainly May were into
June they're still counting it they're
going to tally this up as a total now
what they're doing is they're
criticizing Donald Trump because he said
that listen the rates are going up
because testing is going up and then he
made a joke I was watching seen on this
morning he made a joke at his rally
saying like it I told him stop could you
test less cuz the rates are going up and
that was turning cheek he said he was
joking about that but then they said
Donald Trump said he was joking about
the rates only going up because testing
that's not what he was joking about no
that being said here's what I never have
you ever seen anything like this in your
lifetime I will say honestly what they
are throwing it goes from impeachment
Russia collusion to Cova that it's his
fault to riots and protests and the
economy as are his and now back to covet
it I've never seen another dissipated
Bob Barr you see that you know he said
it would voluntarily justify its just
political theater they are doing
and you can see them setting it up this
is gonna go through the fall this is
going to know there's gonna be a
recurrence of this I know the media has
always been biased but have you ever
seen it this bad with a sitting
president it seems so consistently
attacking I mean you just you know every
day if you go through CNN it's amazing
yeah new articles they can come up with
that the headlines are attacking over
and over and over and over again and
when whenever you dive down into the
facts you never find them you will I
will tell you if you get past like
paragraph 8 they'll throw in yeah a
difference right fact or a counter fact
or something they'll say blah blah
blablah of twitter users said blah blah
blah about Trump he's a negative
horrible person and then nine paragraphs
later would be like experts say that
that Twitter user was on crack reads Bob
underscore Snopes when you need them to
the drugs of the users a very nice
service but basically on this no I all
he's basically saying is we know there's
a ton of other people out there that are
infected with this and when we start
testing more we're gonna see that yes
confirming that it he's basically saying
well if you don't if you're freaked out
right now
I can stop testing a little bit that'll
make you feel better it's not going to
change how many people are infected yeah
but nobody has any common sense there
are a couple of things going first off
yes rates are going up because testing
is going up now there also could be a
component to this where overall
transmissions and infections going I
think it's a combination of both yeah
the riots have been going on for is it
four weeks or five weeks now don't ask
me
the Tulsa rally took place two days ago
so if there is by the way I feel like a
dog because someone's watch is
reflecting on the wall right there I
think it's a laser from antiphon but I
do think there's probably some of that
going on because of the vine and keep in
mind the Tulsa rally was one day and you
want to mock Donald Trump because he was
told by kpop fans and it wasn't full
because they reserved a bunch of seats
so by by your count even though you were
by the way congratulations North Korea
while South Korean sorry I guess it's
not me some North Koreans for
interfering with democracy but you said
6,200 people let's compare it with the
riots you're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people millions of people
across the country for days on end
living in tent cities hmm
with no toilets so I would say
considering the Tulsa rally was two days
ago if you are seeing an increased in
infections it might have something to do
with the violent riots with people
screaming and foaming at the mouth and
they go many of them are wearing masks
it only takes one did not wear masks and
I saw hobos taking big fat corny dumps
and tents who were not wearing masks so
I think that's enough
it was probably barbecuing on Memorial
Day it was though it was all those
people the coverage the coverage is very
interesting because for example New York
Times today there one of their lead
swords by coronavirus targets bars and
churches and the Trump rally right or
any gathering related to Trump right but
they never talked about the tens of
thousands that were in Brooklyn for the
museum opening they don't talk about
protesters they also just conveniently
forget that de Blasio is out there
cracking down on Jewish communities who
want to gather as they have historically
done and in their communities in these
very tight-knit communities but is
letting entire areas of bars just meet
and mingle in the streets right right
getting complete violation right and
then he gets out there any wag his
finger and he's like I'm gonna do
something and these welding shut the
doors of parks and Jewish neighborhoods
right right so when the parrot transfers
from sideburn to sideburn contact well
yeah you know especially if they're
curls right well I feel like Mel
Gibson's calling de Blasio like are you
are you one of me are you with me with
me are you cracking those curly fries
what is wrong with you now I don't know
but I'm working on me I'm working on me
well you know what go ahead go away and
work on you don't come back when the
work is completed I think we're just
gonna find out later like that there's
some like girl when he was in seventh
grade that broke up with him and she was
Jewish she wasn't really Jewish she just
said she was Jewish and couldn't date
him cuz she just didn't like ya and then
now it's like built this whole thing up
in his head right at least that's why
she told me why does she stand up for me
[Music]
but I will give you one more chance I
don't want to miss him exchanging parle
[Laughter]
told you every bed all right we're gonna
go we'll do the RAM thing afterward
because I was very surprised that these
guys here had never seen and will do
that off off air when we will be on mug
Club only these guys have never seen
Rams fighting Billy Goats was very
surprised so I'm excited about that but
first Jimmy Kimmel so they're trying to
cancel Jimmy Kimmel once again let me
kind of rattle off what happened before
and then some things that you may not
have seen of course there was the there
was this people are offended a horrible
response to the Megan Fox interview
right they basically said that they he
implied that he likes to have sex with
fifteen year olds and then of course
remember the blackface I did with Karl
Malone
right I think we have that those are the
things that happened before Megan Fox
caramel on blackface and then he decided
to take two months off this summer how
convenient that must be by the way hit
the notification bell if you are here on
YouTube right now because and hit all
notifications because descriptions don't
mean a whole lot if they do then of
course just check in every day this
shows dreams in the mornings at 10:00
a.m. Eastern and all the time what you
may not have seen however and this is
the recent one is his Snoop Dogg parody
track that he did a while back in which
he so I'm not gonna accuse him of black
voice and frankly I want to be really
clear I don't think Jimmy Kimmel should
be canceled right I understand the
hypocrisy but I don't believe that
conservatives want to live by this sword
as well or libertarians or free speech
activists because I also don't think
anything that Jimmy Kimmel did was that
offensive other than it not being very
funny uh so this is his parody of the
Snoop Dogg track that has gotten people
mad
[Music]
yeah Wow
so I want to be clear what he said there
yeah wouldn't be funny if we got banned
from YouTube for and I think half asian
go on it's not a parody actually because
that might be cover it was actually just
he just sounded like Snoop Dogg saying
the n-word so it's like there was cover
where he could be like oh I was just
doing a parody of them you know no
that's actually pretty bad you were
aching to say it but here's something
else to do a lot of people haven't seen
it only as like 75,000 plays on YouTube
I assume that everyone knew this you
guys hadn't seen this at all before
today no Jimmy it's kind of like Trudeau
right where they go out and they're all
outraged about blackface and it's not
they maybe did it once it's that this
was their thing yeah like Hoover did it
yeah
Kimmel did this quite a bit speaking of
drag here's an old sketch of Fanta in
blackface again as oprah winfrey my body
is my temple that's why I start every
morning with a brisk aerobic workout but
I can't do it alone workouts are easier
when you have a partner my workout
partner is my mate Marguerite Marguerite
soft brown stomach protects my knees and
ankles for a month necessary wear and
tear so you know I mean much like Amaya
here's the problem if I say am I
offended peoples are white privilege so
I guess I should be the only thing that
really offends me is the famed offense
from Jimmy Kimmel because these people
go out and I can't believe it did
blackface I can't believe that megyn
kelly said well you know what back in
the day blackface was dressing up as a
black character wasn't necessarily
considered racist you know we wanted to
go out as I think she would she said The
Supremes or something she said it was
some or Diana Ross whatever it was that
she said she said no it was meant as a
compliment because we looked up to a lot
of black women so that person Megan
Kelly gets cancelled now with the golden
parachute I yes sign for that but I
don't want him to be cancelled here just
as remarkable to me that they go out and
attack people when like don't you know
the Internet is a thing people will find
this
with that kind of dirt existing on you
like you should really just shut up and
be silent about all of this and it's not
like there was any reason for him to
have to do that it's not like they
couldn't have had a black woman do it he
wanted to dress up like a woman and
Oprah and blackface yeah and I will tell
you this when we started off when I was
always dressing up we didn't have anyone
aside from me and like one other two
other people working for us none of whom
at that point we're women to dress up as
women appeared of entire staff that was
the man show there's no excuse
I I don't know like my reaction might be
like I'm like oh my gosh is in current
times knowing that he's going to be
roasted for this it's just there's just
no cover for him he cannot find a safe
place to hide but I think you're to your
point is he actually going to be
canceled do you think he's actually
gonna have to go away for some of this
why no well he's he's away for a little
I mean right now must be nice and I get
two months break especially me of all
these just look that let the executive
PR people try and handle it though but
you might come back to not having a job
so I think he knew that this was back
there
yeah and he said all right I'm just
gonna go until it go away until this
blows over my guess is his response will
be well this is just a concerted attack
from people who want to draw attention
away from their actual racism and go
back to perpetuating these same exact
cancel culture that's what I think we'll
probably see that's what you see them do
often like the real problem in this
country and then people who are dumb
enough to like vote for job I nope relax
ace in trans blackface stomping on a
Mexican made wow there's just so many
levels
everything about that should be
offensive to the left if there's
something good like if there's something
that you get anybody cancelled it would
be that I don't want Jimmy Kimmel
canceled I don't wanna be as clear as
possible I see conservatives doing it I
get that it's fun pointing out the
hypocrisy I would like to see Jimmy
Kimmel go out and change his views and
say you know what listen this has gotten
ridiculous we're trying to hold people
to today's standards from things that
people had done many many years ago in
Canadian that's not that long ago in the
90s right there was no outrage when he
did Karl Malone there was no outlet was
there was so little outrage even the
people who went back and digging didn't
find the Oprah clip you're probably
seeing it for the first time now there
was no outrage when Billy Crystal did
Sammy Davis jr. not even from Sammy
Davis jr.
yeah and it could very well be that
Jimmy Kimmel didn't remember that he did
this it didn't register in his mind as
being something some kind of no really
light of his career or something no I
think I mean what I'm saying is like it
may not have stood out because it wasn't
he's done it so many times I mean during
the champ is pound for pound and overall
world champ is gonna be Trudeau it's got
to be true you know it comes down to
severity of the incident of black face
versus frequency right so like Trudeau's
a volume puncher where's Norton was just
you know that Rocky Marciano lineup like
and this is gonna be a really rough that
was a rough one
that's a rougher than Oprah Winfrey I
mean I mean that's pretty that's pretty
bad I think he goes I think he might go
away from this I really do like I think
if he if he has to come back in the next
couple months with the black lives
movement still going on yeah if it still
got full steam I think it's very hard
for them to bring him back especially if
these things get plays I don't know are
they making the rounds well there's what
I do hope I hope and maybe you can
clarify I hope this it's a legal
precedent because YouTube in a lot of
social media they've banned people for
things they've done off the platform
yeah right so for example we got in
trouble for our socialism is for FIGS
shirt which had a fig leaf on the shirt
we had to remove it with the box had
pocalypse to a piece of powers that
hadn't wasn't even wasn't even while
it's not on youtube was available in a
store in a store that was linked to do
and then you see people like Alex Jones
there are other people who've been in
trouble for things that they haven't
done on the platform but off of the plot
them somewhere else Jimmy Kimmel did
this at Comedy Central right well I
don't know they all have a Comedy
Central not the album that was in Comedy
Central would be a third-party producer
right the point is though if you're
going to apply the standards here a guy
saying the N word repeatedly who's a
white guy and doing blackface several
times and he has a huge channel on
YouTube and direct support from YouTube
and often featured it's a part of this
new sort of multimedia conglomerate that
you see between YouTube and NBC and ABC
and CBS they would have to get rid of
Kimmel if they're applying their
policies equally so I hope maybe that
gives some cover to other people who
maybe didn't do blackface or repeatedly
yelling n-word but you know maybe said
for example like Walt hair that
transitioning
putting them on hormone blockers is a
bad idea BAM there's just this there's
you know folks are gonna call this a
slippery slope but we're not talking
about a hypothetical slope we're talking
about what clearly has happened from
YouTube over the last three or four
years right and that has accelerated
over the last six months as they listen
to the mob that says we move from one to
another and cancel and cancel and cancel
cancel and we will just listen to the
biggest sponsors or listen to
constituents or employees in one
particular part of the country and
ignore the rest of it nor the fact that
the platform was open and now it has
become under scrutiny not only from
additional guidelines but the subjective
use of those guidelines to edit content
right and here when you look at an
example like Kimmel right weird weird
does which one we look at many well I'm
with many examples but I would even ask
a question right saying you know you
know if I was to tell a joke about
Asians right you know what a black man
be able to tell a joke about a black man
is that stereotypical so no instead
we're actually saying that it's okay if
a black man says it but it's not okay if
an Indian person says it all right white
person says it or whatever it may be and
what's interesting about that is you
were literally judging the content of
the statement by the skin color of the
person and that's really hard to do
because you mentioned an Indian in South
Indians give certainly if Shaun King
there's a whole kaleidoscope of Nestle
moustaches yeah they give a dress elbow
a run for his money they have to be very
very dark very dark yes very dark lots
of Sun it usually beautiful beautiful
dark Indian lady okay Wow exotic let's
go to I don't even want to say this
isn't a sacred cow cookout because I
think a lot of people don't know this
about Muhammad Ali
I didn't can you think of any civil
rights celebrity now I don't mean like
Jesse Jackson I don't mean like Martin
Luther King or Malcolm X I'm saying a
celebrity or an athlete who has been who
has been turned into more of an icon of
the civil rights era the Muhammad Ali
very few very few I can't think of many
because you're talking about a guy right
who people remember as a man who sort of
dodged the draft and it went up to the
Supreme Court because he was saying why
am I gonna go to look well I'm not gonna
go fight a country when my country won't
fight for me ain't Vietcong he done
nothing to me you know that cold deal so
I didn't remember that and they remember
him having a problem with the United
Sates government
hold them up and a lot of black lives
matter and some people with Muhammad Ali
estate have been trying to cash in am
hamid Ali's name here's what's
interesting is his actual son I believe
let's just I think it's Muhammad Ali jr.
I'm not mistaken I don't know if I'm not
mistaken let's make sure we have that
name Ryan is June I'm pretty sure I know
it's oddly jr. but you know they have so
many names sometimes when you have the
Nation of Islam and they have their
change different name yeah that's like
Creed we need four of those like hey
let's take rocky everything you like
about it the characters a soundtrack
yeah none of it and we'll call it Creed
so Muhammad Ali's son he said that his
father would be vehement Lee against
black lives matter and I want to be
clear this isn't a quote taken out of
context because you see us a lot people
take a quote and go see and the person
says Allah Allah second that's not what
I meant to say which actually happened
with Muhammad Ali's senior when people
tried to say that he spoke out against
Trump and he went out of his way to
correct it so I want to be clear here
but let's read some of the quotes from
Ali jr. this is from the New York Post
he said it's impressive but okay let me
preface this Ali Jr because what I'm
about to read no doubt would register as
white supremacists oh right
you know going and kicking our butt with
a trash can shield that's what they
would think you are this is Ali jr.
Muhammad Ali's son and then we'll get to
why you're wrong about Muhammad Ali no
he was actually a conservative and
probably hated you using him so from New
York Post my father would have said they
nothing but Devils
my father said all lives matter I don't
think he would agree with the black
lives matter movement I'll lead junior
and Muslim like his father said I think
it's racist it's not just black lives
matter white lives matter Chinese lives
matter all lives matter everybody's life
matters huh well right there all lives
matter right that's a that's a that's a
white supremacy dog whistle or what
we've heard that's by the way honking
blowing it
but he's just blowing it at a statue of
Jesus because it's like that's not gonna
take it down he's hopeful doesn't matter
how much you huff and puff it's still
Jesus he's walking around at them
he thinks it's built out of straw it's
not he says God loves everyone he ever
singled anyone out killing is wrong no
matter who it is then when he was asked
about the police right specifically an
don't even get into some of the things
we said about the George Floyd case
because I think he goes too far the
other way we don't even necessarily
agree with right yeah but he said police
don't wake up and think I'm going to
kill n-word I won't say don't not Kimmel
so I don't have the hood right I don't
think they don't wake up and think I'm
going to kill an n-word today or kill a
white man he said they're just trying to
make it back home to their family in one
piece now this is interesting because
this ties in to Muhammad Ali or before
his death where they tried to say he was
anti-trump he was actually anti Islamic
terrorist vehemently so yeah so his son
said these people black lives matter
they're no different from Muslim
terrorists they should all get what they
deserve they're effing up businesses
beating up innocent people and
neighborhoods smashing up police
stations and shops they're terrorists
they're terrorizing the community I
agree with a peaceful protest but the
anti-fur they need to kill everyone in
that thing kill everything in that ping
you're calling that group a team strong
views on answer for there but he says
black lives matter reiterating sorry if
this seems a little bit dry but I think
you should know this black lives matter
is not a peaceful protest an tyfa never
wanted it peaceful I would take them all
out and by the way let's use I lead
junior ladies and gentlemen let you
think this is a guy that grew up in the
lap of luxury and privilege he only gets
a thousand dollar stipend from his dad
per month from his estate right and grew
up in on the south side of Chicago one
of the hardest places to grow up and
have that opinion that's kind of a dick
move the relationship fell apart in the
last decade yes it was kind of well
that's what people will try and say the
relationship fell apart but let me point
out here that the apple doesn't fall too
far from the tree you remember the Civil
Rights icon of Muhammad Ali well guess
what people mature and they change and
like all people they become more
conservative as they get older and they
have children they pay taxes they have
skin in the game yeah that's what
happened with Muhammad Ali I want to be
clear Muhammad Ali first off he moved
out to the suburbs because of all the
crazy violence that he hated in in
Chicago right and actually shouldn't Joe
Frazier nee he used to call up joy for
Joe Frazier and say some really racist
stuff it was actually pretty funny there
were kind of buddies but not really
frenemies when asked what he thought
about Africa this is after the rumble in
the jungles I hear he said thank God my
granddaddy got on the boat Wow now let
me be clear because you'll say well
maybe that's not indicative of Muhammad
Ali himself being more conservative
because we have the quotes from his son
and the son is speaking about his father
and then his son is speaking for himself
and we have Muhammad Ali shape-shifting
as used in Africa he did endorse Ronald
Reagan now I know you'll say well at
that point he just had to endorse Ronald
Reagan because who else was it well he
could have endorsed anyone else but he
went out of his way
so you see national politics he went out
of his way to become active in local
politics and the only person he
passionately almost campaigned for but
certainly endorsed publicly vocally
repeatedly Orrin Hatch you
sons-of-bitches watch that says white I
mean what you talk Mormon happen they're
not they're gonna be talking about
anything and then Muhammad Ali had a
statement on the Muslim travel ban I
don't know if someone can actually bring
this up I don't think I have it in front
of me but he made a statement on the
mountain the travel ban can we scroll
that so I can see it or can Gerald to
bring it up really quickly this is where
he said I don't have the exact quote but
here's the thing what did happen was he
was talking about people in the in oh
very clear our political leaders should
use their position to bring
understanding about the religion of
Islam and clarify that these misguided
murderers that have perverted people's
lives views on what Islam really is so
then people came out and said oh this is
a shot at Donald Trump across the bow
right right over the travel ban and they
said that he was referring to people
meaning they tried to imply that he was
referring to Americans as murderers and
we were taking out terrorists no no his
statement was actually about taking out
all of the Islamic terrorists he went
out of his way by the way spokesperson
to respond specifically the parachuting
San Bernardino Muhammad Ali later in his
life was crusading against the current
state of Islam and yes he was still a
Muslim but he said you got to stop with
the anti-jewish speech you got a
stop with the anti-israel speech and we
need to take out all of these Islamic
terrorists who warp the view of what
Islam really is and here's the thing you
may disagree with that if you look to
Mohammed and I've talked about that but
I don't I don't disavow the idea that
there are plenty of Muslims who are
trying to change yeah it's the course of
religion now and bring it into the
modern world and Muhammad Ali was one of
those men you know again even at the end
of his life when people try to say
Muhammad Ali speaking out against Trump
and now they're trying to say Muhammad
Ali doesn't need your pardon Donald
Trump right the estate because they
collect money it's kind of like when we
got sued by the Bob Ross estate and then
we realized they had nothing to do with
Bob Ross and the family hated it but in
other words the easiest thing to do
would have been for Muhammad Ali to say
nothing but he endorsed Ronald Reagan
yeah the endorsee campaign for Orrin
Hatch and then when he made a statement
about the horrors of Islamic terrorism
warping the view of Islam and he was
saying we need to go and take out these
murders and he saw that the media
misquoted him to attribute it to Trump
he went the easiest thing would have
been say nothing he went out of his way
to say no no no no not Trump wasn't
aimed at anyone specifically certainly
not Trump it was aimed at Islamic
terrorists so of a hamid ali who you
think you know is not the man he was for
the majority of his life if you look at
the praise for what he did you think at
the praise for what he did afterwards
when he became an anti segregation right
right he realized that segregation ilysm
which is what he believed in when he was
younger right he didn't believe that
black men should be with white women or
vice versa right he realized and
understood that it was wrong and he
spoke out against it and he would help
people regardless of color but for some
reason black lives matter want to hang
on to this idea an image of a young
angry and ignorant Ali which is what he
would tell you exactly okay we're gonna
get to know we're gonna go I'll go we'll
talk about it because I want to hear you
have to say after but right now it's
time for everyone on YouTube well first
you should go of course join a lot of
credit accomplishment clip and watch it
live at the blaze TV we'll take your
chest but for right now YouTube you can
piss off